so Mike how long we've been doing this
show I would like to say 28 weeks but we
did skip a few when you're traveling it
is our 28th episode though and to
commemorate it we're gonna be talking
about 28 days later Mary I think you
wanted to touch on 28 weeks which
whatever now I don't really want I went
20 I don't like it but it is our 28th
show to a degree and it's our we're
doing an episode on 28 days later and
then to culminate everything else it's
our first episode in video yeah so
obviously if you're listening on iTunes
or wherever else you might catch us this
is not going to be any different but if
you're on YouTube or gamespot or
wherever we post this this is my dumb
this is my dumb mug here we go I was
like why are you only get to see it now
yeah well I also need coffee I I'm tired
uh but yeah so I'm like my hearty I've
been hosting this for twenty seven
episodes that's Mary over there she's
gonna be switching this live so she
might sound a little awkward today while
she figures out this thing I also might
switch a few on accident to the wrong
person yeah but you've already done hey
Peter that's Peter Brown you heard his
sonorous voice plenty of times by now if
you've been a fan of the podcast I yeah
that's just a game spot and this yeah a
fan of GameSpot I don't know like where
I mean audience is coming from Justin's
the person who would know that you're
all analytical and whatnot now nobody
knows me that's Justin hey wold uh yeah
it's pretty pumped to talk about its
Justin I think like 28 days later you
said is your favorite horror movie or
one of them it's definitely in my top
three best I think it isn't one of the
best horror films of all time yeah and
like that the beginning like it's so
iconic like that beginning just always
stands out I can watch that are on an
endless loop like it's so it's not even
scary it's just that that mood that it
sets up is so perfect for the rest of
the film 3.net malik yeah and it really
does a good job of as the character main
character is being introduced to things
introducing you as well and
like same questions he has you have and
super evocative as well at the
composition of a lot of those shots yeah
that good the London it's like
sun-drenched when he wakes up but it's
also a lot of shadow 2 it is that where
the walking dead got the idea for what's
his name the main character to wake up
and from a coma and the world has gone
to [ __ ] the official answer is yes
Robert Kirkland told you not I don't
watch the walking dead anymore I can see
that is an idea that somebody would have
in a vacuum but or just not even realize
like oh yeah I saw that in this movie
and then it flavors the way that the
walking dead was created but it's it's a
good idea like that's that is a way that
you would survive a zombie apocalypse
potentially i like the little world
building they do too like when he goes
up to the hospital door the key has been
slid under the door so you imagine maybe
like a nurse or one of his family
members those visiting like the parents
he goes and he finds that they had
killed themselves just took sleeping
pills with wine and their home in
deptford actually whereas where i stayed
when i went to london which is really
weird because any other time i watched
that movie it didn't mean anything that
i visited London lately so like oh [ __ ]
I know heard effort is it was really
cool but yeah you're like oh maybe one
of his parents just kind of slid the key
out of the door in the hopes that maybe
he would wake up or a nurse or a doctor
someone and then when he goes downstairs
in the hospital lobby all the phones the
pay phones are swinging from their cords
and like what happened and then like he
kind of picked him up and listens and
just throws them so you're like oh
someone was either in a hurry to check
them or it's like didn't care and like I
don't know painted a pretty cool like
what happened when he was sleeping
without actually i'll write telling you
there's a really good job of setting it
up without too much exposition they also
start setting up like right from those
opening shots that you're you're dealing
with protagonists that know what they're
doing which is something that didn't
always happen in zombie films of that
era this this zombie film which is
released in america in 2003 did a lot of
things differently than most zombie
films the most iconic was the gimmick
that they're fast and they're not
zombies they're infected right it was
about ready a viral infection that's
through the blood and saliva so that was
like their first premise right zombies
fast you know they are they're fast and
they're going to come after you but the
second one that they did that's very
very unique is because it's set 28 days
later all these stupid people are dead
and you are not dealing with someone
who's crying or freaking out or doesn't
know what to do all those people have
died and you're dealing with four main
protagonists that function they can
function in this world and that's really
unique so right from the get-go in this
hospital he is hot thirsty he's been you
know I don't know what he's been getting
for the last month but not nothing
substantial and he sees um a vending
machine and he grabbed some soda and he
chugs it not only does he do that but he
gets a plastic bag and he filled it with
three more cans because he might want
them later so it's kind of like setting
the tone and this is without any words
yet by the way besides him saying like
Hello mm-hmm that you know to a degree
you were as confused as he is your on
this journey with him and he's not an
idiot and all those things are just such
a wonderful exposition to this has also
been passed out so you get to discover
the world at the same time that he does
that everything every idea that he gets
about what's going on every explanation
that as we made it feels logical because
he's also been out of over 28 days yeah
and that is Cillian Murphy which is
super weird cuz i just finished the
season two of peaky blinders on netflix
you guys watch that I mean he's been
he's been like scarecrow from the Nolan
trilogy of Batman he did inception he
was the one they were in his dream so
it's weird to see him really young here
this was yeah release in America what 13
years ago I forget what the actual
release date this is his breakout role I
have a good tidbit about this his that
role um his name is jim was originally
offered to even mcgregor and even turned
it down and then it was offered to Ryan
Gosling and they had a scheduling
conflict thus Cillian Murphy stepped in
in basically his first very it's like a
larger role and I think it it pretty
much started his career in many ways
it's weird to see Danny Boyle
potentially jumped to an American actor
after not getting you and McGregor yeah
I was gonna say Ryan Gosling when I like
that young the last thing I remember him
as he is the cornerback and remember the
titans that's the only like ever
whenever people look at Ryan Gosling now
they look back remembers has a holy [ __ ]
that's Ryan Gosling just like I don't
know 18 or whatever he was but I yeah
then Selena who's the character
who hurt character arc is actually a
little more interesting to me than most
of them she just starts off that as that
hardened survivor which you don't suit
the she's uh she played Moneypenny in
the newer on the Daniel Craig James
Bond's but she the way they show you how
much of a survivor she is when the guy
you first meet her with gets bit in
Jim's home in deptford and then she
immediately starts hacking him with a
machete and you kind of like no I mean
if that's the first that's not the first
zombie movie I've seen but it was
earlier on and those in it that kind of
just pragmatic approach to killing the
one person you've been friends with for
four weeks now is really unsettling she
just goes for it because he got bit on
the army trail [ __ ] goes back to a mary
was saying right like everyone is super
smart but like mmm that doesn't mean
necessarily good very lot of evil people
running different shows in this world
that's what the army commander later on
says the gym he's like how many people
have you killed he's like right how you
know if killed some he's like if you're
if you're still alive you must kill
somebody and Frank is the father who
they introduced him pretty cool selena
is almost running away from Jim up those
apartments tears when she gets up to uh
where the guy who played Matt I moody
and Harry Potter Africa the actors name
but he he is like he's got a riot shield
an outfit you could tell like they are
used to this his daughters in the house
and he's like go down to like five be or
where the apartment is and he is very
like a jovial guy for the circumstances
they find themselves in and his like to
jump a little bit in the timeline his
death scene is brutal my god well let's
do this well slow down I think it was
cool about like those characters is how
you're right like they all have
different wants and needs and they're
all displayed really clearly and in this
film so like Jim is trying to figure out
what's going on and he's the best to be
associated with us The Watcher right
like he's how we perceive this film is
through his eyes selena is like this
badass who I just think is just an
incredible character right she's she's
hardened i believe the director like had
a backstory for her where she like
watched her parents died like that's why
she's such a cold [ __ ] but it works
really well and none of that's stated
it's just implied because she's so
aggressive like when she leaves him in
that famous seamer they're like running
up the stairs and he's
calling out to her like wait for me and
she doesn't because she doesn't give a
[ __ ] about anyone she can't afford to
she knows they'll get them killed and
then Frank's Frank's motivation is to
protect his daughter Hannah they show in
that opening scene in their apartment
there's a family photo of Frank Hannah
and them and the mom they do not discuss
the mom ever so it is just implied that
she dies and Frank knows that to protect
Hannah he needs help which is why he
puts the lights on on his place in the
first place to get more people to his
place to help because he knows he can't
do it on his own well today at little
beauties are always going to be very
important you do it's always sunny
reference right yes it's just out of
nowhere yeah there's been a few on this
show so far but no it did they were
outright say that it was the disease
that killed mom because she had
potentially been dead before hand I
figured they just got divorced they
don't bring it up you guys are reading
way too much into this no I like that
but that you don't know I guess it
that's why i like this movie doesn't
bother telling you every detail but then
I don't know like I really like how
probably my favorite scene in the movie
is when they go to the grocery store and
it's there it's like the one good moment
they have and I it's weird because I've
had that fantasy kind of getting locked
in like a mall or grocery store
overnight really we have stoned for your
Ain to go whatever like do whatever you
want obviously they're confined to like
the canned goods but I would just
destroy like little Debbie's or
something you know we have there were
used to be game shows I don't know if
they still have them but like
supermarkets week so we got you just run
through a supermarket guys remember that
Toys R Us thing or on Nickelodeon one
once a year a kid would win like in like
10 minutes and a toys r us in a shopping
cart is whatever he could get mm-hmm it
was a double wrapped I want like 15
baseball mitts like what would you have
gotten here yo games come on yeah 15
nintendo's one at toys r us you had to
get paper slips it's all you gonna do is
it [ __ ] yeah you can just put those like
a little notebook and then grab one of
the you know that toys r us always have
the bicycle aisles yeah get one of those
bicycles with the cart behind it yeah
and then don't even worry about a
shopping cart load that [ __ ] up and then
you could fly around the place and it
permitted their own zombies knocking at
the door to bring us back hey I think
like something that the
uh that scene did though that is really
smart is a lot of these types of movies
again this is something that kind of set
the precedent ahead now was that it
would just be like something scary
happens that you get to relax for a
second something scary happens you get
to relax for a second but this movie
doesn't just let you relax it actually
lets you start to enjoy so that scene
isn't just calming it's enjoyable like
you kind of laugh there's artic yeah
there's like a scene where Frank is
explaining why there's like a really
good scotch to gym and he's just like
it's a just got like a harsh start and
then it's a camello aftertaste it's got
a Pernod it's got a fire but it doesn't
burn yeah it's got the fire without the
burn oh yeah um Jim just turns around
and walks away cuz you can give a [ __ ]
and it's just like a really good dynamic
like there's comedy there's like another
scene where they're enjoying the food
and like having a picnic and then
there's like another scene 2 it's
actually right before that where they
see a pack of wild horses totally free
and having a good time and it's like
that just that's not just a break like
you've just made that scene really
lovely and that was pretty new for for a
film to do something like that to be
cinematically beautiful in between all
that gore there are a lot of good
details and then going back to the mom
when they first get there he's like you
have anything to offer our guests and
she's like we have mom's creme de menthe
that's on the top shelf or sad serious
like and then he paused for a little bit
he's like oh it's like he's like oh I
wish we had some better but also like
yeah what happened to mom why the [ __ ]
did she like creme de menthe who was
addicted to Chris drank her away with it
from the meds uh yeah that was do you
mentioned I don't marry you wrote the
run of show today you said there's a
tidbit about girls with the empty shots
of London was that do you remember why
yeah and I found like some cool facts
about it so uh this used to be as well
as Justin this used to be my favorite I
think it still is to some degree like my
favorite zombie esque flick attending
supplanted yeah when I had the DVD I
watched all the DVD with commentary and
all the behind the scenes there's a lot
of good facts in there and an alternate
ending which is a look at them yeah
antics I definitely want to talk about
that but one of the cool facts was you
remember like there's all these iconic
scenes where they show completely empty
parts of
parts of London that should never be
empty including some like really famous
highways that are jam-packed and always
the book the bridge he first walks over
is the Tower of London stop I
underground I've been to London so cool
my weight I'm gonna keep driving at home
no I'm just kidding he's been places uh
London was established in 1995 by George
Bush he that guy went over there and
said hear me this is London um they
recorded those at four in the morning
and they would they got attractive women
to stand where they were holding the
traffic to make people less angry so I
could get a little bit more time out of
it and they could only do it for a max
of an hour yeah and even that was
pushing it and they did it for like 30
seconds of usable footage it was like
very impossible very lucky shots yeah
and they used the ladies to get him and
they didn't tell the London Police
Department they're gonna blow up a gas
station no they didn't yeah that was a
surprise maybe sick hey surprise every
scientist I think was inadvertent so
they didn't do it to be because they
didn't think they can get away with it
yeah but the director was like nice yeah
Boyle just like [ __ ] standing there
with a wreckage behind him and just like
middle finger to the police station
smell of gas in the morning yeah there
was a firefighter chops to his knees
what if that happened nowadays that be
just chaos anyway Twitter would go nuts
yeah there's Twitter be beefing with it
there's crazy visuals scenes in this
entire film but like that's what made it
so visually unique at its time and I
think another one of those really famous
visual scenes was um the tunnel this is
where they get a car they decide as the
four of them before protagonists are
gonna like kind of go and seek out this
base because they find an audio thing
that's saying that they found a cure
it's like Manchester or something yeah
and they go into this tunnel and they
drive over all these cars and of course
they get flat because crazy oh sorry to
interrupt that's also another good
moment when they're driving over the
cars because they all like start
laughing as I got thrills that was kind
of one of those
brief moments where they were human
again yeah you're totally right and
after they get the flat I think we all
anticipate like don't aldol but it's
such a cool way and they do it they say
I'm they're like what's that noise and
they're just like heaps of rats come
through and then when they realize the
rats are running from the infected which
is a very interesting concept you can
see all the shadows of the infected
running through the tunnels it's like a
very iconic scenery or just like seeing
all these shadows like crazy people
right and they're sprinting well its
immediate it's also the thing that
struck me I don't I was wondering if the
rats were infected because they're like
swarming over Hannah who's under the car
would like trying to I guess like get
the jack under the cars they could
change the tire and then the rest are
swarming over her face was like a [ __ ] I
hope they're not infected yeah it's
another good example though of how they
don't freak out because they're smart
and they're survivors so you're not
seeing the girl who you think the young
girl would absolutely lose it and like
be crying in a corner she's changing a
tire while the other three lift the car
because they don't have time to like
jack it up so they're just they're just
doing everything and everything
everybody's doing their part and even
though they're freaked out and I'm sure
they're like screaming inside everybody
does their job because they're not
stupid and that's why this movie's
awesome yeah and then I mean the real
horror sets in i don't know if I'm
jumping ahead too much when you realize
what the soldiers intentions are with
selena and hannah there say the
commander gives that speech to Jim he's
like he's essentially giving a choice
he's like you can either die or get in
prison or just like let us try to start
repopulating because I said like we're
pretty much waiting to die what are we
going to do like we've tried exploring
the area as well we know there's no one
left we are just kind of waiting out our
extinction and then two women show up
one who's for 15 or something young
teenager and then Selena and everything
in there start to realize they're like
oh they're gonna they're planning on
raping them to repopulate and or just to
have sexual relations again when they
never thought they would and then Jim of
course like gets thrown in jail with
that one cop who's also protesting it
and they kind of it's the scene where
they're all pointing guns at him and
they start to like back him into that
corner you're like what is he going why
is he doing that like Oh [ __ ]
standing up to them cuz they're that's
what they're planning on that that was a
pretty dark moment you have to realize
going on that entire sequence of the
army is pretty cool because it seems
plausible it seems plausible that a
group of individuals alone for 28 days
would establish a hierarchy which they
already have because it's an army and
that they start to get depressed and the
army guy when he's making this like
pretty wild speech after he after things
start to get a little shaky right with
the ladies in the men and the army guy
is basically saying I'll tell you what I
see I see people killing people and
that's what I've always seen and that's
a really important statement that he
makes because what he's what he's saying
is this is in a moment where all of a
sudden were infected we're dealing with
the infection he's saying people have
always killed people we've just an hour
just this nothing has changed in the
state of humanity now we're just in
control now just like [ __ ] thing to
say that's the root of all good zombie
movies that it's not about necessarily
the infected it's not about the horror
of fighting things that can't die it's
the horror of how it reveals real human
nature and who we are on the inside yeah
the zombies are more of almost like a
setting than an actual character in it
and that shows because that's that's
silly Murphy's character are key
eventually becomes a monster himself to
the point where Cellino and he's it's
dark in the room after he kills a the
one who's got like captured her he kills
him and then she looks at him she thinks
he's infected she's about to like hack
him again with a machete but she stops
when she sees his like his eyes are
normal his face is normal he has dreamy
eyes silly Murphy's eyes are nice he's
he takes a turn for the worse I mean
when they take him to kill him so they
take him and the other army guy I mean
he was a sergeant I don't know if he
even had a name honestly and charge
Sarge ol Sarge and they're kinda getting
really bad like the army guys are
basically like oh I'm gonna stab him
instead of shooting him because they're
just like mentally out of it and that
gives Jim almost call his character's
name the ability to escape that's kind
of where he snaps and what's really cool
about it is that's the twist is
well that's the what a twist moment he's
laying on his back and he looks up in
the trees and he sees a plane and that's
like that moment where you realize that
the world is not stopped turning
everyone is fine the world is going to
continue we're not out of women yet we
just we've quarantined the area and
those guys went [ __ ] nuts they went
nuts and that's how they dealt with it
was that hierarchy that army base
hierarchy so that's where Jim like loses
it and he does something pretty sneaky
he like turns on the alarms and starts
trying to take him out one by one it's a
really really really good scene it's all
done in the rain it's beautiful yeah
they uh his name's major Henry West is
the leader and he he shows Jim that the
undead they have chained up at one point
forget the undead's name but it's pretty
weird because they're trying to figure
that out that's like their overarching
plan is figure out how long it takes to
starve all the infected but also lure
with these radio signals wherever was
like female survivors yeah that's pretty
smart to the mansion the man or wherever
they are I do I want to talk about
Frank's death scene now cuz poor friend
it's so [ __ ] up because the whole time
they're avoiding the infected and these
running zombies but you forget that I
can just you be transmitted by the blood
or saliva and he looks up because he's
shaking the fence to get the bird to fly
away mm-hmm and then the blood drops
down if the shot is like in the blood
drop and drops in his eye and it takes
in like a few seconds to realize that
that screwed him over and then of course
like hannah has to watch her dad turn
right in front of her and you wonder if
that is the first time she's seen that
but it seems like it was but I don't I
mean like I haven't watched my dad
turned into a zombie mmm-hmm or an
infected a rager no but it was it's a
mess up scene and it's pretty pretty
awful you see like someone's humanity
slip away and it was pretty sad it
happened so quickly to its they say
15-second transitions so it's like as
soon as it happens you have to kill them
and he's um he's still halfway there and
he's saying um the last thing he says is
i love you very much and she starts
ragin he just starts kind of freaking
out and i don't know i mean it's a
really quick scene but i think you could
start to get cho
dup right before the army shoots him a
bunch in his chest he is just a shock
and then he's the sweetheart in the
movie right like he's the real nice guy
yeah he was the comedic relief he was
the one that kind of gave us like
brought us back yeah that's the what the
best zombie movies or stories do is show
they how it changed characters knob
viously Cillian becomes a monster
himself at one point but he becomes a
survivor essentially but selena becomes
a little softer because you actually ask
people that care about between a gym and
hannah but then it you forget that like
hannah she gives her a ton of like
vicodin or something he had before they
think they're gonna get raped so then
like hannah herself [ __ ] crawling out
all the soldiers yes she's like you're
all gonna die yeah and then Cillian just
climbs up on top of the fence covered in
blood with his shirt off in the rain
like what what is he doing he's gone
full primal at this point and he's
basically like got his eyes open and
he's like in the window like yes thera
and then uh then like the infected start
slowly spreading throughout the mansion
taking everybody out and i like how that
culminates that whole thing what were
the alternate endings besides the one
where they just like they put the help
sign they've been showing it in the
remote like london countryside and then
the plane flies overhead right there is
one where like it just like maintains
that it's hell and the lead character
died in the hospital or whatever yeah
that he died and then that's a really
weird one and i think i also when we're
talking about setting the precedent of
this film it's like one of the very few
that have a positive ending but it
earned it it's not positive as a twist
or like to shake it up it like deserve
to have a positive ending they did lose
one character but it wasn't because he
was stupid and like went off on his own
it was just a mistake it was an honest
mistake that he like got something in
his eye and the other three were
hardworking and killed anyone that got
in their way survived and they kind of
deserve to survive so that was pretty
cool to watch that and then in addition
to though that alternate ending ending
when he died there's also one that never
even got shot it was scripted and
storyboarded where they kept the father
Frank
and they do a full blood transfusion
with a regular person to make him human
again and they were like oh yeah that
doesn't make that would that would
actually be impossible for us to
literally replace every drop of blood in
his body right with a new bot person's
blood I'm sorry trying it's really
stupid and I think that's why they
didn't shoot it but it's cool that it
got that far and there's storyboards
with the actors and everything kind of
going through the motions in case they
end up going that direction just pretty
wild so obviously they thought of
options yeah like it's it's going
through those those three main beats
both one where the hero doesn't die but
it's still kind of a happy ending and
one roots know everything shitty that
made here the main guy dies and it
doesn't seem like anything's gonna ever
be good again did you watch the mist yet
no I'll haven't because speaking of
horrible endings well good endings but
like just abysmal good endings but like
really dark and dreary I mean and I
think almost every horror movie to like
now ends up really bad like it's about
how you end up dying right like that's I
mean you look at things like The Walking
Dead it's like about how everyone dies
it's not meant for survival it's meant
to show people eventually dying and this
is a long enough timeline yeah on a long
enough timeline you're all going but
this movie was always meant to have an
end from the very beginning it sets the
precedent that these people are infected
and they're not eating they're not
eating brains here so they're going to
starve to death come on yeah and within
a very short movie it shows a bunch of
the infected starving it shows them
starving to death so it's showing you
that this was meant to end that's a part
of the beauty of this much like many
things it's not meant to have sequels
which is why it shouldn't have had a
sequel that's equal sucks 28 weeks later
it's bad you watch that reason didn't
you watch that instead of 20 days
because you knew 20 days well enough I
know 28 days really well so I thought
I'd watched 28 weeks later to get
refreshed and that movie does not hold
water I hold an old [ __ ] sucks I saw it
once when I stewball water 17 of them
put the most abysmal of waters how do
you remember the age you always have an
anecdote for I remember where I was mom
no I was in Annapolis he does too I was
in Annapolis Maryland
with my friend Tanner burn in London I
was from James Joyce it was for 32
hapless Marilyn I was on page 475 so a
second breakfast once i saw that no it
was it was I was watching Marilyn I
remember I was gonna watch like my
friends who were you wearing that day uh
probably won't cross me just throw it
out and I remember watching it I
remember the beginning most of all I
remember the chopper scene when they get
a chopper and the pilot like inverts his
bird so to speak not a sexual away and
then yeah he starts spinning like you
know we don't want to say that in a
sexual way but like you you would never
put the blades down like that would that
would destroy your helicopter it is
stupid I think that's actually the
moment where I was like oh wait this is
a bad film um cuz they made a lot of
mistakes right like there's just like
simple things you just don't feel that
way when you watch 28 days later
everything felt plausible everything was
like yeah that is probably what would
happen right they would quarantine area
they would vacate the area and he wake
up butt naked in that bed oh yeah hey
jude hangs dong that's close out that
you want to talk about things are
unbelievable what hospital just has
patience lying around it's really naked
in 28 days later yeah doesn't you wake
up just completely naked yeah he's naked
but he could have had a gown on and
where'd the gallon go Mike tossin and
turnin asleep and you know it gets hot
and you rip it off in your sleeve and
maybe is when you laid an inverted a
burden gown without throwing off you
just don't know why a nurse wanted to
get a last look like a really nice time
I seen before I go oh it's beautiful
yeah then runs out the door throws the
keys on the floor that's how that
happened I'll never let go this is my
last hurrah Cillian Murphy I hope you're
not listening I mean there's a lot of
thing we're watching me but they're
plausible you know after he goes out of
the hospital he goes to a church and
there's just a mass amount of dead
people in that church and everybody else
is vacated so why is there a bunch of
dead people in church well it's because
a bunch of religious people were like
[ __ ] the world is ending and they all
committed mass suicide that seems
freaking possible it seems completely
like something that would
actually happen in such an incident
where as in 20 weeks later sorry to
bring this crap up again but they
reestablish society in case anyone who
hasn't seen this atrocity they
reestablish societies they vacate it but
then they're like cool we fixed it
there's no infected we're bringing them
back in with the army right and they
have everybody in like a nice contained
quarantined area they thought everything
through there's guys patrolling
everything they're taking this [ __ ]
seriously and they don't want to get an
infection again [ __ ] i just remembered
the scene with jeremy renner sniping all
right yes so that's another scene but
let me tell here where when they get the
very first infected the very first
infection happens that crap this is
happening we need to isolate it you what
they do do you or what they do they put
every person in one room and lock the
doors and turn up the lights that's what
you did lauren teen anyone hide for
playing coordinate that's not what you
do when you have an infection really is
it you want to make sure that if its
ranks not everybody gets it yeah and
then yeah and then sniper scene sucks
too i go back to the church yeah so all
the people in the church end up dead
because they poison themselves that's
what I think sure okay but not the
priest that's right what a dick yes
right yeah and it's all it's all unsaid
right yeah he's just he's infected which
means this is religious in theory he was
like everyone drink this kool-aid and
then he SAT amongst him and was like
just kidding I'm gonna totally live he
didn't take them away at the last minute
and one last round for donations if you
don't I'm going to kill myself but you
know I'm totally drinking it it's for
the church yum yum yum someone about the
body maybe he had good intentions um
it's like littered with possibilities
that are untold and that entire thing
I'm glad you brought up that priest
thank you yeah it's also creepy as hell
when he comes in and says hello in the
church and the two that are a lot the to
be infected likes just look up at him
really quickly oh that's creepy yeah
that's shot but they're not eating any
one right like it's also establishing
that this isn't one of those ed type
zombies rage those people are just angry
and everyone else is dead why and
cillian murphy swings his bag of
groceries at the priest says sorry right
after it yeah klima crawling toward him
my cans yeah my Saudi pops canned goods
survive apocalypse apocalypse my purse
seen them in 28 weeks kind of yeah I do
now and you were just saying you hate
Jamie jeremy renner yesterday yeah I
really don't like looking at that guy
he's a pretty surreal dick breath I like
in real life that he supposed to be a
real ass how do you know something like
that stories of people on the Avengers
there's a thing called the internet when
people tell things other people you
can't believe those things like your
puters a real dick to that this podcast
is a lot of truth to that but your own
stories on his podcast about him just
being a [ __ ] real [ __ ] Lord shitbird
invert wait why'd you why'd you wanna go
back to sniper scenes or something
specific or you Swan harp on it this
just another battle yeah I remember I
remember the opening um the dad is the
guy who played the villain and James
Bond the world is not enough with the
bullet in his head who survived most the
movie but knows he's gonna die so it
becomes this dastardly villain that's it
I remember the opening and it's along
this country river and he's got two kids
with him I wouldn't be there Mike when
did you visit that River oh I think I
was about 25 no I would've been 24 at
this point um no no not onto us we've
gone too far and with my age jokes to be
fair I actually do think the opening
scene is really really well done all
right buddy just practically separate
from the rest of the film doesn't he
just bail on his kids he did he leaves
his wife could just roll credits after
the opening see it just leave it like I
think when they done marketed a short
story they showed that as the marketing
for the film I'm curious the intention
yeah like you didn't know it look I
thought it was a one off piece hmm and
it was really good as that one off piece
like it's so good they're like eating
dinner and then like there's a kid in
the front door and they're like which we
let them in and the woman is like of
course you have to let him in it's a
child you always let children all your
own children in and so that works out
but then all the zombies come in and
they just
kind of come they just start getting
taken out one by one and it's pretty
brutal especially and this is this
juxtaposition of happy happy didn't end
in time which is what i call dinner and
crazy zoms are like coming through the
door and you don't know what to do about
it that's what i call dinner za Dom time
bomb time so they go upstairs and the
mom is trying to get the new child the
one that's actually totally screwed them
over by I even being there and [ __ ] that
kid the dad is like we have to go and
she's like we can't leave him so she
will she goes to get the kid zoms come
through the door and the dude looks at
her and she goes I can't remember his
name she's like my husband name as you
say and he looks at her he just jets out
the door and as he runs away he looks
out he looks to the window and she's
against the window like this she gets
like uh oh I don't remember that like I
know I saw it and I remember he's a
little moment but a trim scene it's
really good and it's only I want to say
like three minutes it's like yeah it's
like five minutes so it's totally worth
seeing and then you should just like be
like cool that was a sweet sequel smash
your VCR that was very cool there was a
prequel only eight days before I me
later what Sandra Bullock go goddamn it
wait wait did I hear you saying they're
gonna 20 months later was in
pre-production at some point there was
talk of it but I don't know where it
ended up going but if what if you did 28
years later and everything's fine it's a
romantic comedy has nothing to do with
the original movies remember the time I
remember like dozen or so years ago like
in a history book and they're just
talking about it for a brief moment yeah
I'm curious you said something earlier I
think justin asks you did 28 days later
gets supplanted by something else in
terms of zombie movies for you all right
did you just oh did something like
eventually become my favorite yeah it's
not like you said it used to be your
favorite um like world war z I think
yeah that's the new one um I could even
remember who the lead actor wasn't it
hey I think I thought it was sadly
pooper
Rep oh sorry Brett peds my favorite
actor brad poober and my holy moly this
is going well um yeah I would have to
say and this is a huge switch from it
but one of my favorites zombies of all
time this is another really heavy twist
and I don't know a lot people even
consider it a zombie film but I would
call it a part zombie film is murder oh
damn it haha J dog would die hard I hard
slither slither is really good it
combines humor it's really witty it's
got really good characters and it does
have zombies in it but it's also sci-fi
it's kind of weird anyway I really
really like it everyone should watch it
but 28 days later is still my favorite
in terms of just gorgeous cinematic
wonderfully done beautifully directed
good characters damn i really like
Selena she's like guys you all hardees
to find good lead characters in these we
talked we did a zombie episode before
and half the girls just freaked out I
just can't function yeah doe survived
which is so different i have like if
this happened in our office guys be free
like I think Mary would be fine no I
think guys would be freaking out I would
might not even have to get beaten like
bitten before I just machine to death
Miley slightest hint of a zombie
outbreak Mary's gonna hack my neck apart
oh [ __ ] sorry I think he's infected
somebody home I just need an excuse to
murder all of you somebody gonna sneeze
me like a [ __ ] and look I'm Mary
sprinting full boring hahaha are you
guys talking of that I'd kill all of you
just we talked about that we talked
about this probably like every few
episodes who would survive a zombie
apocalypse out of the gamespot staff
that's right and what we would do Nick
margaritas mosley underground he was
almost gonna come on this episode but he
forgot to watch the movie god damn it
yeah wino newly honk anyway but that's
like probably a good overall of 28 days
later yeah one of the greatest one of
the greatest of all time it was all time
it was a good movie to commemorate our
20th episode
I don't know if you know that that's why
we did it I said at the beginning
episode but say you were listening at
that point so are you gonna do that on
the thirtieth episode that 30 days of
night or wherever the hell that movie is
ya know we're gonna do uh hey mother
numbered horror movies have you ever
seen Josh Hartnett I am sure glad it's
not that it's a josh hartnett right in
Alaska it's not great with vampires
because it's based on a graphic novel of
the same name it's quite good it would
be so easy for us each week to talk
about the walking dead but I refuse I
don't like that show what you're talking
about it right now some reason I guess
no publicity is bad publicity except I
hate that show is it because you hate
the shore because you hate your roommate
I hate where's the show um man wow just
got real I don't like my roommate who
I'm just kidding um I don't think this
podcast on video so I mean you talking
about Jake Decker right yeah um wait
when did you start hating it I I dropped
off episode two no it's uh season three
midway through season three it's not
that I hate it it's just like the
creators have like specifically
expressed the fact that like we want
this to keep going forever that's right
point like okay so we're gonna draw it
out yeah gonna like this new dude
everybody's freaking out about there's
that I saw an advertising on the subway
the other day said uh it showed negan
the villain and said he's like we're
just getting started and then someone
tweeted I said dude you're on season 7
Yeah right just getting started soap
opera it's a soap on it is and I think
there is again like there's that is
something to be said about something
that's meant to end and how that can
make a piece so much more beautiful I
the idea that they don't have an end in
sight it does not feel good let me you
in my magic night with me as far as
what's gonna happen later on go on or
what happened first I'm not gonna tell
you what happens in my imagination
understanding i would love it if the
creators would allow me to use it
instead of just telling me what's gonna
happen every step of the way just write
down your thoughts and send it to them
in a bottle with a cork in it i read the
comics for a really long time and i
stopped a few years ago and a little bit
after the point where they're at now in
the show it is just like just a little
things please it's just wear it no it
never ends your you just
have characters and feels like you're
going to really similar situations so
it's like West World Series what rotten
episode four no I've cut damn it if you
watched it oh you mean those living the
same day the movie with Bill Murray and
the zombies and that he relives the same
ghostbusters that's what it was oh we
should talk about zombieland I love that
my do not like zombieland Mary's giving
us the wrap it up single summation about
so maybe that's oh I just had a weird
tangent with office and I forgot what it
was here comes another tangent no I'm
done now you okay yeah oh just all right
fortunate that is all the time we have
today well it's not but I'm gonna make
it I'm not gonna let you just keep going
like the walking dead because then this
[ __ ] happens I'm just let it make it
good and end it on a good note that was
dead air see you next week no um email
dead Eric gamespot com as always gives
some suggestions we're gonna you know
like keep doing these on video from here
on out maybe we'll like I don't know
decorate the set or something so it
looks more horror if 'ok able to turn
the lights off and be in the dark you
just be staring a boy though we'd like
screen the less we hold any their face
Oh flashlights are you afraid of the
dark style yeah I like it you uh yeah
review us on iTunes you give give us
less than four stars don't review us oh
my god now you can see this on youtube
gamespot uh yeah thanks for joining us
if this is your first time seeing us
some video go back and listen the last
twenty seven episodes and then imagine
what you've seen transplanted into those
yeah now you have faces to put with the
voices bless you cool so that's all the
time we have this weekend we will see
you next time
you